>> NI-LEWIS: Bam.
Welcome to The Friday Games Review.
>> GALPIN: Oh, yeah.
Rolling in again.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Bam.
>> GALPIN: Welcome again, to The Friday Games
Review.
>> NI-LEWIS All right.
>> GALPIN: I'm Dan Galpin and with me is Ian
Ni-Lewis.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we're kicking it old school
today.
We decided, we've been doing a lot to bring
the quality of the show up and you know lots
of new shots...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...lots of new effect, lots of
new...
>> GALPIN: Low quality today, that's we were
at, man.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Today, we just dragged out the bar table,
we got the beers and honestly, we're just
going to talk games.
>> GALPIN: Yup.
>> NI-LEWIS: And if you guys want to stick
around, that's cool.
I'm not going stop you.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
And we want--we actually have looked at the
moderator page and guys, stop nominating stuff
we've already looked at man, come on.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm also like stop this garbage.
>> GALPIN: Well, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I was kind of bummed about that.
>> GALPIN: But now you know, there's some
good stuff here.
But you know really, man.
We like--we've already reviewed it.
We're not going to review again unless...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN...unless you've done like something
just totally kick ass awesome with it
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
But seriously you know, hey, we're tired.
>> GALPIN: It's been a while...
>> NI-LEWIS: We had some week, yeah.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, it's been [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, lots of--lots of stuff
going down here at work but...
>> GALPIN: All good.
Good stuff.
>> NI-LEWIS: Good stuff for you, I guess.
Anyway, point B...
>> GALPIN: Dude, we're going to get promoted,
man.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, there you go.
All right.
So, anyway, we've got a lot of stuff to talk
about but I think we're going to--we're going
to do a little bit of game review or think--we're
just going to talk a little bit about games.
We've actually been doing--we--every now then,
we kind of do a sweep of a bunch of games
that are popular.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: To see you know, how well they're
working on different devices and if there's
any issues with them...
>> GALPIN: Developers do very...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...performances like.
>> GALPIN: ...interesting things.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: That's what we learn.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, yeah.
We've learn some really interesting things
that I think it would be fun to talk about
them and at the same time we'd like to you
know, look at a few games.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And maybe mock some, maybe not.
>> GALPIN: It's possible, yeah.
Well, you know, we have--we have--we have
our good friends from Com2uS nominated a game
and their games are always fun because they
don't--they aren't intended to appeal to my
cultural norm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Do you remember when we had to
send that one game back?
And say we're not going to feature it unless
you take out the giant red...
>> GALPIN: The falace.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I guess it was supposed to
be a rocket.
>> GALPIN: It was, it was, but it--the problem
is when you make a rocket with two giant round
orbs on the side of it.
It really does have the wrong impression.
>> NI-LEWIS: Especially when the nose is kind
of purple.
>> GALPIN: Yes, yeah, absolutely.
It was...
>> NI-LEWIS: Anyway, today, we're drinking
Lagunitas IPA.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
Cheers.
We need this today.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a gift from our friend the
Famster because I've totally run through my
beer budget and I'm not going to start spending
on something else like wine.
>> GALPIN: Beer.
No.
You're not--come on, it's the beer budget.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true, that's true.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: No, actually you know, what I'm
spending it on now is audio stuff and lights.
>> GALPIN: And lights?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup, because we need key lights.
We need key lights...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...coming right back here shining
down on your shoulders...
>> GALPIN: That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's going to make your hair
look luxurious.
>> GALPIN: So, I'm wearing a hat again because
there was some public outcry about the fact
that I had no hat last week, so once again.
But what is--what is fun is I'm actually performing
in an opera right now in my spare time.
>> NI-LEWIS: I thought you said they're going
to make you cut your hair for that.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, they were going to.
But...
>> NI-LEWIS: And you rebelled?
>> GALPIN: Well, no.
I didn't actually...
>> NI-LEWIS: Your cast members rebelled.
>> GALPIN: Actually, they first tried to put
me in a wig.
And they put me in a wig that was--honestly
like the $20 wig special.
And I looked I was a game show host.
And you know, when you're in an opera where
you're suppose to be in like 1890 or something
like that and you look like you know, Wink
Martindale.
It just--it just doesn't work.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, Wink Martindale.
I miss that guy.
>> GALPIN: I do, too.
>> NI-LEWIS: [INDISTINCT] of him, anyway.
>> GALPIN: But they did make me actually dye
my beard.
This is--this is not the normal color.
So, it shows...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I noticed them.
>> GALPIN: ...a lot better on video.
I think I'm going to go...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: ...go Zorro for Halloween this
year because I--do you think I'm rocking the
Zorro look?
>> NI-LEWIS: Probably.
>> GALPIN: Like fat Zorro is where going forward.
>> NI-LEWIS: And juts because we're probably
going to die half-way through when the YouTube
stream cuts out.
Might as well say right now that next week,
it will be a perfect time to talk about Halloween
apps.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
And Halloween games.
So, you know, we're--we're going to actually
have a two weeks of Halloween games so you
know, it doesn't actually say so the moderate
pages yet, but please nominate some Halloween
games otherwise, I'm going to nominate them
so yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I don't think it's really a risk.
I think that there is...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS:...plenty of--in fact, most games
have come out.
>> GALPIN: There's so many zombie games out
there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
>> GALPIN: I mean, seriously.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Right.
>> GALPIN: Now, here we are.
It's Farmville with zombies.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> GALPIN: Zombieville.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: There actually is a game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Actually, so I'm really excited
to see if there's going to be an Android version.
My--one of my old co-workers from Project
Offset did a mobile game called brains.
It's a zombie real time strategy game.
>> GALPIN: It's right up your alley.
>> NI-LEWIS: You play--you play the zombie
horde.
>> GALPIN: That's awesome.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: That's very--to me, it's interesting.
Okay.
So, it's--I'm looking forward to that.
That sounds cool.
And--so right now, we'll say the closest we
have to Halloween, is we do--we do have witch
wars on tap for today.
>> NI-LEWIS: But it's not really a Halloween
witch.
>> GALPIN: NO, no.
There sort of your sexy anime witch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: That's the way we describe it.
So--and it's weird because you pointed out,
they do have handcuffs.
It's one of the things...
>> NI-LEWIS: No, let's...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...do is judge for themselves.
>> NI-LEWIS: So just take a look at.
Now, you'll notice that we've completely [INDISTINCT]
today, we don't have any titles or anything.
>> GALPIN: Nope, you'll have out figure out
what we're...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> GALPIN: ...looking at on time.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a mystery.
>> GALPIN: Disconnected to the server.
Ops, ops, wait hold on.
>> NI-LEWIS: Basically what we did...
>> GALPIN: The game is back.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is, if there's like a lot
of hating in the YouTube comments.
>> GALPIN: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, first, we'll discount 90%
of it because that's what you do with YouTube
comments if you want to remain sane.
No offense.
But...
>> GALPIN: Wait--did we start out saying,
that's the real question.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, that's what I was going to
say.
>> NI-LEWIS: And of course I'm not talking
about any of our live viewers because they
all rock.
>> GALPIN: Point being.
>> NI-LEWIS: That I--we are kind of like just
winging this show today...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ... but we'd love to hear--yeah,
a sort of you know, counter point what we've
been doing before which is kind of like slick
and over produced I guess.
You know, what do you think?
>> GALPIN: Yeah, let us--let us know if you
want us to continue over producing, we can
do that.
We can make more three titles.
>> NI-LEWIS: We...
>> GALPIN: We can use more effects.
We can use more green screen, we can--we can...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right, baby.
>> GALPIN: ...we can--we can have us on freaking
Mars man.
Now for the next--to the next show...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
>> GALPIN: ...it's up to you.
>> NI-LEWIS: I've got a green screen, a bonus
burning, a whole in my pocket and a year's
subscription to Adobe CS6.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, better watch out.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
Exactly man.
After--we're going to use After Effects on
your but so let's just...
>> Uh-oh, guys, I'll just put a lower thirds
for you guys.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, no.
You didn't [INDISTINCT] rock on.
>> GALPIN: He just do that, you know, he does
that to spike us.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
We have lower thirds now, so yes, the title
is Witch wars and let me tap restart.
>> NI-LEWIS: No, wait a second, Dan.
>> GALPIN: Because you'll see the witch is
exempted at the beginning.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right, there's a witches, okay.
>> GALPIN: And [MAKES SOUND]
>> NI-LEWIS: So excellent.
And Dan, this game play it's really interesting
to me.
It seems like...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...there's a bunch of things
here.
>> GALPIN: They're talking.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: That you need to match.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: How many do you need to match?
>> GALPIN: Three.
>> NI-LEWIS: Three, really?
Okay.
>>GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's interesting.
And there's like a grid of them and they're
all different sorts of objects.
>> GALPIN: Yes, but I'm playing against another
witch.
You see?
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> GALPIN: So, she's like--she's like kicking
my butt now because you're talking.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well...
>> GALPIN: Wait, you're ruining my game.
>> NI-LEWIS: So what you're saying is, I'm
talking so you're not getting any work done?
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
Hey, wait.
I'm sending--I'm sending a message here.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm just saying.
>> GALPIN: No, no.
So anyway, yeah.
So, play it man.
>> GALPIN: I'm restarting, okay.
Oh, witches.
>> NI-LEWIS: Is it always the same witches?
>> GALPIN: I don't know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
And then the question is, yeah, why do did
they have handcuffs?
>> GALPIN: Well yeah, that I didn't understand
the handcuffs part.
Is there--is there--so let us know in the
live stream, is there a some sort of witch
thing of handcuffs that we should be aware
of that you know, that we--I understand like
you know, that--the star pentagram and stuff
like that you know, that's--that kind of stuff
like that, the Star of David is kind of sort
of witchy thing to some people.
But yeah, come on, tell me what this is what
this is?
I don't get the symbolism here.
Maybe I'm trying to read too much in this
game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that is weird.
There's a Star of David.
Shouldn't it be like a pentagram?
>> GALPIN: It should be a pentagram, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Is this like just all completely
messed up?
>> GALPIN: It's possible.
I just don't know.
I honestly, I haven't had enough to drink
yet to get this game.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you are a little--do you
want to just take a break?
>> Guys, I'm just going to jump in and read
you guys in one of the comments?
>> GALPIN: Okay.
>> So this is from one of our long time viewers...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> ...FunnerGo he says, the last minute title
card actually looks better and then the formerly
over produced title card.
>> GALPIN: That's like--that's awesome.
That is not--we are--we are so, okay.
Okay.
Good to know.
I blame...
>> NI-LEWIS: No, he's got--he's a good point.
>> GALPIN: I blame Keno for that actually.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I'll tell you what happen
is we--yeah, we threw together that--that
thing in Keno and it looked good at the time
and then, one of the reasons we don't have
it now, is because we got really sick of it
and didn't like it at all.
So...
>> GALPIN: You're with us actually.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
We're totally with you.
>> GALPIN: We're--when we actually have time
next week, maybe we'll do another one that's
cooler.
>> NI-LEWIS: But you know, just so you know
that's not a thrown together title card.
That is in original Roman of New York title
card.
For which, we paid vast sums.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, his salary.
>> NI-LEWIS: Vast sums.
All right.
So, what is this have that other match free
games don't have?
I think it's a question you will always got
to ask.
>> GALPIN: It is--it is a battle element--oh,
she's crying.
She lost, I totally won.
Hey, new witch.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it's got witches and a handcuffs
and battles and spells.
And it's actually pretty cool like, honestly
it's fun.
Where there spells?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
We get spells by matching up certain skills
you see and then you can cast spells.
Dude, level one explosion.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, nice.
>> GALPIN: So, yeah.
So, it is--I mean, honestly, it's fun.
You know, if you like these kind of games,
there's ones that really have a lot more depth
in terms of, like, progression, like, you
know, one of my favorite ones is called Atlantis
that I actually played all the way through.
From players, they talked about it a few times
on here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Because I like the fact that you
actually got to different cities and got to
different challenges.
And--but, this is fun for what it is.
It's sort of--it's sort of reminds me actually
of the classic puzzle fighter in the sense
that you're sort of, you know, you're--you
know, you're kind of battling against someone
else.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
That's what I was thinking, you know...
>> GALPIN: You know, but taking it to match
3 instead of--instead of to, you know...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-huh.
>> GALPIN: Puzzle Bobble kind of thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> GALPIN: So, you know, I'd say cool.
Nice Match up with game donors.
>> NI-LEWIS: That is cool.
>> GALPIN: I always appreciate match ups.
As far as the graphics, we have really kind
of low res backgrounds with high res icons.
If you actually look, you will get--I don't
know if you can see this in live stream, but
if you actually can see, like, the versus,
it's really kind of blurry and the backgrounds
are really blurry.
But then the icons are beautiful, like...
>> NI-LEWIS: You got to ask yourself if...
>> GALPIN: That's...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they did that and the--and
the [INDISTINCT] just decided, "Okay, this
background is too big, probably you'll notice
if we just blur it out a little bit and make
it smaller.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
You know, I--they--and I'm sure they are trying
to make the APK size small which I appreciated.
I would say one thing that was great about
today, all these games installed in, like,
four minutes.
Like, honestly, they were...
>> NI-LEWIS: Wow.
>>GALPIN: ...they were all tiny games.
>> NI-LEWIS: Unlike Bard's Tale.
>> GALPIN: Unlike Bard's Tale.
Yeah.
Last week and I was, like, installing Bard's
tale...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: ...which by the way is awesome.
Thank you inXile for doing that.
That's like--it made my whole week the fact
that we had Bard's Tale on Android finally.
But, yeah, it's freaking enormous and mostly
because of the song about beer, beer, beer,
tiddly beer, beer.
Oh, I got stunned.
>> NI-LEWIS: It is Tommy Tallarico, you don't
cut out his songs.
>> GALPIN: No, you don't.
You absolutely don't.
And it's Kerry Ellis as the--as the narrator--not
as the narrator, as the--as the Bard.
So, you know, you got to appreciate that.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true.
You know, the funny thing is I think the last
time I played Bard's Tale...
>> GALPIN: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...was actual Bard's Tale, like...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
They--same here.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...when they came out...
>> GALPIN: I miss the PS2 version...
>> NI-LEWIS: And what was the [INDISTINCT]
it actually comes with that.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And it's not nearly as good as
I remembered.
All right.
Yeah.
>> GALPIN: When you're...
>> NI-LEWIS: Back then a 240x240 graphic in...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...like 16 colors, it really
blew me away.
>> GALPIN: It was Awesome.
Yeah.
It's, like, how did they get so many colors
on the screen, man?
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Well, because I had a VGA monitor which...
>> GALPIN: Oh, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you could put in the 256 color
mode as long as you're willing to go down
to QVGA.
>> GALPIN: So, one thing that's interesting
about this game is this game actually uses
Com2uS's...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
>> GALPIN: ...network back in the game.
>> NI-LEWIS: Dude, you've totally stepped
on my reminiscing.
>> GALPIN: I know.
I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
But you didn't even say anything.
You didn't say--you didn't say, like, "Oh,
shut up, Ian.
Let's talk about this."
You just like acted, like, I wasn't even talking.
>> GALPIN: So, no.
I mean, I totally--I totally miss that.
Actually, you know, one of my favorite thing
was I had an original, like, you know, CGA
adaptor for my PC and most people didn't realize
that if you actually hooked it up to a composite
monitor and you had the right games that could
actually display 16 colors at once.
So, that's how the original...
>> NI-LEWIS: What?
>> GALPIN: ...King's Quest worked.
And it used the same methods in the Apple
II.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, oh, right, right, right.
Because it--yeah, it does--it was like a--was
it scam line or was it block?
>> GALPIN: It was block.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, the block pellet, right?
So, and basically you would--you would--you
have two lines, you put them right next to
each other horizontally and then you end up
getting the color on...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...composite because of the, you
know, kind of affect--raster effect you got
from that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: Similar to what you got on apple
II.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Do you remember the Commodore
64 did that, but they didn't actually have
enough memory, so every pixel on it being
twice as wide?
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Back to Witch Wars.
>> GALPIN: Good days.
>> NI-LEWIS: Witch Wars.
>> GALPIN: So, yeah, and so overall, you know,
pretty good.
I mean, my main--my main thing is it like
it pushes the Com2uS social network into,
like, new levels of annoyance if you don't
want to actually use it.
But the game--the game plays...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, come one.
>> GALPIN: No.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's not--I mean, what is it
doing?
>> GALPIN: Well--okay.
So, the first--let's see if I can actually
replicate it.
I might have to clear the...
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean--well, I just didn't--I
didn't see it come up or anything.
>> GALPIN: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: They all take a really long time
to load.
I don't know why.
It's like refining swords and, like, "Dude,
what--are you copying something to the--from
the EPK file?"
I mean, this game is tiny.
Like, I'm not sure what it's doing, delivering
skill books...
>> NI-LEWIS: That is what it is.
>>GALPIN: ...like is it caught in the network.
I just want to play.
I want to get my witch action on and...
>> NI-LEWIS: Delivering handcuffs ordered
from the shopping mall.
I mean, seriously there is...
>> GALPIN: There is something...
>> NI-LEWIS: There is something up with [INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I know.
This game, I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: I don't--yeah.
I don't know how to interpret this, but I
don't think I want to.
>> GALPIN: So, then when it comes up actually,
I ended up getting--you end up getting the,
you know, some sort of news.
It looks like it's actually being nice to
me the second time.
It's not actually forcing me into lots and
lots of stuff.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> GALPIN: Which is cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it gave you some ads up front.
>> GALPLIN: It get--well, not add--not just
ads, like, kind of a general--okay, maybe
I signed--I don't know.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm sure these guys know what
they're doing.
They make, you know, oodles and oodles of
sales in--especially in Korea.
>> GALPIN: [INDISTINCT] I didn't--I like O-ker
and--instructions.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, yeah, they...
>> GALPIN: I would--I would say they don't
quite know what they're doing.
They're close.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, it's just they don't--all
right.
But my personal theory is that they're--most
of their translation department is, like,
nephews and...
>> GALPIN: Well, I'm just saying that, like,
this is a--the word wrapping thing though
here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, actually let me explain
it to you.
>> GALPIN: Okay.
Okay.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
You and I...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...wrap words on...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...syllables...
>> GALPIN: That's because we wrap.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know what this is?
>> NI-LEWIS: This is how you do word wrapping
Gangnam Style.
>> GALPIN: All right.
All right.
So, anyways, we'll quit.
Let's go--let's go to our next game.
I figured that I have to look--we have to
look at Happy Sheep.
>> NI-LEWIS: We have to look at Happy Sheep,
but only because we want to know if anyone
on the live stream can explain this game to
us.
>> GALPIN: The sheep are happy...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, they're very happy and
it's like--I mean, I think--I definitely got
past the first level and I'm pretty sure I
knew how I got past the first level.
I just...
>> GALPIN: All right.
Play button really close to advertisement,
clever.
All right.
So, your goal is to get the sheep into the
barn, I think, and you do that partially by
flicking them, I think, but mostly by using
the [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: You know what, flicking is not
actually a part of it.
>> GALPIN: Oh, it is.
>> NI-LEWIS: It is not a mechanic.
It's--because if you try to--wow.
Because if you--if you really pay attention
and just tapping them.
>> GALPIN: Oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: I don't think it's actually requiring--well,
so basically you put the barn at the bottom
of the screen and just let everything fall.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, I guess so.
So, the sheep are happy.
Mostly--you know, and that's good.
They have--they have one frame of animation
on them which is, you know--which makes them
look happier.
There's a dog.
I'm not sure what the dog does except that--I
guess it blocks you from getting sheep in
if it happens to be in the right place.
>> NI-LEWIS: That doesn't make sense.
It seems like the dog should be helping you
get the sheep in.
>> GALPIN: Totally.
Totally.
But, you know, dogs don't--you know, you do--you
do have sheep dogs that are, you know, that
go with sheep.
Oh, we just lost HDMI because, you know, microHD
my socks.
>> Yeah.
It flickering.
I don't [INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: There we are.
All right.
But anyway, so that's the game.
You could see on the tablet, we're seeing
some minor sprite alignment errors.
You can see the classic around the chickens.
You can see there are little lines around
the chickens and a little line around the
dog and this is pretty common if you're using
a sprite sheet and you're trying to break
things up and run on the...
>> NI-LEWIS: Carefully, something...
>> GALPIN: ...of higher resolution.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
All right.
Stop playing that game, seriously.
>> GALPIN: Oh, yeah.
What?
Why?
>> NI-LEWIS: Because you keep tilting it around
and it keeps popping out the connector.
>> GALPIN: Oh, but I'm holding the connector
in now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, you're not holding it right.
>> GALPIN: I'm not holding it right?
>> NI-LEWIS: Put it on the table.
>> GALPIN: Damn it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Just put it on--you know what,
you're cut off.
Come one.
Come on.
>> I have a couple of great comments from
our viewers.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, please.
>> GALPIN: Oh, yeah, go for it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Let's hear some viewer comments.
>> So, the first comment is that flicking
your sheep causes blindness, I'm just saying.
>> NI-LEWIS: I have no idea...
>> GALPIN: Good point--good point...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...what you're talking about.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
>> And the second comment is that someone
wants to see us abuse the green screen in
horrible ways.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, believe me, we have.
>> GALPIN: We already have, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: We're already saving it for the
outtakes video.
But...
>> GALPIN: Dude.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I will say this about [INDISTINCT]
the sprite outlines that you saw...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...did not occur without the
HDMI connector plugged in.
So, this is something that we're actually
starting to learn is it's really, really important
to go in and test your game at really bizarre
resolutions.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because sooner or later, no matter
what resolution you think is never going to
in the real world...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's going to hit the streets
of Shenzhen at half the price of everything
else.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And Samsung is going to snap
up a bullet load of them.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
You know, it's--I mean, people are--I'm always
amazed on what we're getting in terms of screens.
I mean, even in terms of last year when, you
know, I was kind of amazed that we actually
had a device which--we're shipping out on
a phone form factor with 720p, that was last
year.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
>> GALPIN: Who knows...
>> NI-LEWIS: And God only knows what's going
to happen...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly, what's going to
happen this year, so...
>> NI-LEWIS: But, it's not just that.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's that you think--you think,
"Oh, 720p, that's pretty crazy."
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But what's really crazy is 735p...
>> GALPIN: Well, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...or...
>> GALPIN: Which is actually that we were
because...
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> GALPIN: ...when you--when you--we're actually--we're
actually at--on this device, we're actually
running at true 720p when you're in HDMI.
But you're not on HDMI, we're in this kind
of weird funky thing where we're actually...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...you know, 35 or 40 pixels short
of that I think.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
And so--yeah.
>> GALPIN: Or longer than that.
>> NI-LEWIS: That can--that can mess up some
sprite sheet calculations, I think.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
So, anyway, it was interesting.
Also, the thing that it's interesting when
you plug the HDMI and you actually--you actually
get one of those rare things where it actually
gets your--tells your app to change the size.
And so your app needs not to respond to that.
We actually had one app earlier that had a
giant purple or green fringe on it and that
actually was because, oh, we just never realize
that the size change could come in as late
as it did.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: So, you do have--you do have to
watch out for that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, you change--you can come
in any time.
>> GALPIN: You're going to come in any time,
you got to be ready for it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> GALPIN: So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I mean, we've said it before and we'll say
it again.
Programming Android is not like programming
a game console.
It's like programming a desktop or a web browser.
You have to be ready for hardware to be different.
<< GALPIN: Oh, so when you select hard difficulty,
you have chickens who are blocking your way
now too.
I hadn't noticed that.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
So, that was fun, but tell us what you have
been doing this week, Dan.
>> GALPIN: Other than flicking my sheep?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Okay.
So, what other games we have going on?
We actually have Words Workout which is fun.
It's yet another in a long line of words games,
but it's done very, very well.
I would say that the excessive use of rounded
rectangles is a little unnecessary in Android.
But there's some good words here like pleat.
Ouch.
And you are, you know, it's a time game so,
uh, oh, well.
So, yeah, we now--we get to learn how good
I am with these games.
Anyways, so it's a fun game.
We were trying to draw things in a sort of
a boggle-esque fashion.
There's a lot of power ups, a lot of really
well-thought out stuff.
I thought it was a really fun game.
On a tablet, it works great, you know, because
it just scales to fill the screen.
The only thing on the tablet is the--obviously
you can see the area with the ad is kind of
awkward looking and takes a very small portion
of that top there so...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: ...probably could just adjust for
that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Especially games like this.
There's really not much of an excuse for not
trying it on the emulator.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And just try some different sizes.
It's a little bit of a pain because honestly,
it--we don't switch as fast as we could...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...between different sizes and
different lay-outs...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS...on the emulator, on the dev
tools, but it's well worth it.
And it turns out that for games nowadays--I
mean, I think we used to see some really bizarre
things.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we still do on some devices.
But as we're, you know, for instances, as
we're looking at devices that haven't shipped
yet which we sometimes do, there can be some
crazy stuff.
But...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Well, you know, it's interesting.
We, you know, we sometimes do it to ourselves.
And, you know, I think one of the things we're
going to cover in future sessions are--is
ways in which we--you have to be careful,
you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: And so, sometimes people make assumptions
about the way the memory in devices are laid
out.
Sometimes there are actually some bugs in
[INDISTINCT] it turns out that were affecting
the way that one could subclass various classes
that people we're accidentally taking advantage
of.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that's actually one thing
you'll notice is that the original Android
source base, you know, was obviously not a
hundred percent perfect and there were a few
things that either were underspecified or
were just done wrong that tend to get cleaned
up over time by AOSP contributors.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, for instance...
>> GALPIN: And by us, and by us, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And by us.
So, for instance we made--for Jelly Bean we
made pthread POSIX compliant.
It was supposed to return an error...
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...if it couldn't give you the
thread you wanted, you know, with the scheduling...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...that you wanted.
And it used to just fall back and, you know,
still create a thread, but it wasn't what
you asked for.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And we made it do the right thing,
which was to return an error and that broke
everybody.
>> GALPIN: Everything.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because it turns out nobody was--why
would you check for errors on pthread because
it never [INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, we had ton of games and other
apps that would spin up threads and then sit
there waiting like, "Hey, all right, just
waiting for that thread to spin up."
>> GALPIN: Waiting for the thread to spin
up.
>> Ni-LEWIS: And--exactly.
>> GALPIN: And, yeah.
And nothing would happen.
So--yeah.
So, you have to be--you should be a little
bit cautious.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Sometimes reading our docs actually
is a good thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: And also just, you know, adhering
to standards even when it doesn't break you.
You know, the other thing that happened I
believe is the Ice Cream Sandwich timeframe...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...was we tightened up the JNI
referencing restrictions.
>> GALPIN: Oh, we've done that several times.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because we, you know, and this
is usually to make things faster.
>> GALPIN: Well, some of the things that happened,
you know, when we add a single threaded, you
know, everywhere.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: There are kind of two things we
did at once.
We went multi CPU.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: And at the same time we also tightened
up JNI and I think they sort of went hand
in hand.
But for a long time, we weren't cleaning up
JNI very effectively.
So, you could pretty much guarantee that if
you reference something from the JVM, that
reference would always exist in JNI as long
as it existed in the JVM.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, basically what we were
doing is...
>> GALPIN: Or [INDISTINCT] let's be clear.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...the "opaque candles" that
were getting passed back were just references
to memory...
>> GALPIN: To chunks of memory and then...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and then the address is the
one changing.
>> GALPIN: ...and now--and then we switch
to actually passing opaque candles [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: That were actually candles.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, because at some point we
realize we, you know, we're not going to make
this GC any faster...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...unless we start rearranging
memory, so.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
So, one of the--of the things everyone should
do in addition to using CheckJNIs is to also
build against the latest versions of the NDK
and build against the latest versions of the
SDK.
Be very, very careful especially with native
tools especially if you're using any pre-built
libraries because that...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...you know, you don't know how
those pre-built libraries were compiled.
Maybe they were compiled with an older version
of the NDK, maybe they're complied with the
[INDISTINCT] flag.
So, in general, I, you know, especially with
binary libraries, be very, very cautious.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, this is--the reason we're
talking about this is because recently it's
become very obvious to us that as we do more
address layouts--address space layouts randomization
and just screw with the address space in different
ways...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...old code that was compiled
with very old NDK is not re-locatable in the
same way that the newer code is and this also
goes for code that may have been compiled
with a different toolchain.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, if you're using some other
random toolchain to generate Android code,
be aware that we only test against the NDK.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, so, definitely, you know,
all you guys out there I know there's a bunch
of other, you know, a lot--a lot--for a long
time Chris Axe was like doing sorts of cool
stuff that we, you know, later introduced
into the NDK.
So, you can definitely run into problems there.
So, just be very, very cautious that you're
always using the latest version of our tools
because that's going to guarantee the longest
forward compatibility that we can.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
All right.
>> GALPIN: All right.
So, anyways it's a cool game.
I--you know, I really don't have much to say
about it other than they really need to make
this dialogue dismissible with the back key
as a general rule.
>> NI-LEWIS: There's not [INDISTINCT] all
right.
>> GALPIN: Zombie.
>> NI-LEWIS: That bad.
>> GALPIN: Back key must work.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's an x for us, dude.
>> GALPIN: Oh, sorry.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, dude, you should be Frankenstein.
>> GALPIN: Oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: You should be hipster Frankenstein.
>> GALPIN: Hipster Frank--with the beard?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
I should keep the beard just so I can be--I
can have--I can have--I have sunglasses [INDISTINCT]
your tablet is not cool as mine because yours
is shiny and silver and mine is blackish colored.
>> NI-LEWIS: This is--that's--it's purple.
>> GALPIN: Purple, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or actually that's--it's amethyst.
>> GALPIN: It is amethyst.
>> NI-LEWIS: And this one isn't silver.
Don't fool yourself.
It's champagne.
>> GALPIN: It is actually.
That is the color they call it.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know why?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because we're the Sex and the
City girls basically.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: That's why we got this hat.
It's all about accessorizing.
All right.
So, let's look--let's look at a game that
actually--unlike Words Workout, it's somewhat
actually--oh, my god that's small.
You can bring up the tablet now, Mr. Fanster.
And, yeah, there we are.
This is actually a portrait.
Yeah, I know.
Look at that.
That is high production values right there.
Now, you'll notice--this is one of those times
in which actually looking at screen size is
useful because by default this is of course
an nDPI device, so you're getting very small
text and very small icons.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> Yeah, Which game is this, guys?
>> GALPIN: This is Math Twister.
>> NI-LEWIS: Math Twister.
>> GALPIN: M-A--now, you can tell it's not
from the US because it's got math in it and
no one in the US would actually call it Math.
It would definitely be a--something coming
from somewhere else, you know, usually with
some k in it or something like that, maybe
Australia.
I'm not sure.
I didn't look for this [INDISTINCT] but clearly
not from here.
>> Ni-LEWIS: Did you know in Australia...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they call soccer, soccer?
>> GALPIN: What?
As you know, originally the term soccer came
from the UK.
And we are not that--and we--and we just kept
using it and they said, Stop, we're calling
it football."
>> NI-LEWIS: I love this because...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's like we can make a 600
mile journey across England in just a few
sentences.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
It all depends on what app are we talking
of the--wait, hold on, hold on, wait.
I got one more--no, I've got--no, sorry.
I can't...
>> NI-LEWIS: Come on.
Give me a [INDISTINCT] and [INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: No, no, don't say that at all.
It's nothing like it.
That sounds bad as the...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's the dude that tried to
sound like Ringo in the Old Submarine.
>> GALPIN: That is so absolutely true.
Well, you know, the funny thing about The
Beatles too is that they actually were coached
to sound like that because they came on--I
don't want to talk like this.
What are you talking about?"
Like no Americans could understand you.
You need to slow the way down.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, really?
Like what's his name in that one movie?
>> GALPIN: Yes, exactly.
So, they said no.
They were--they taught them.
They actually said, "You've got to slow down
the way you speak."
Like, "All right.
Well, we'll speak like this then.
And then yeah, we'll sound like we're always
on something."
>> I think you mean Brad Pitt from Snatch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: What?
You didn't know that?
Because that's what I was talking about.
Dan got it.
>> GALPIN: All right.
That's enough about us.
Let's get on to Math Twister.
So, you know, I'll go with a bit more of a
refined accent for this.
Math Twister is a highly educational game.
We can choose untimed and different levels
of difficulty which will throw math problems
at us.
You know what is 10% of 80?
Or two times seven?
Or six times nine?
Or 10% of 70?
And they get kind of fun.
I have no...
>> NI-LEWIS: And you're now George Harrison's
butler.
>> GALPIN: That's right, something like that.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: By the way, I just want to--I
just want to pause for a second to recognize
our new producer, Producer Louis who...
>> GALPIN: Louis.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is not might.
>> GALPIN: No, he's not.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Sorry.
>> GALPIN: So, he's...
>> NI-LEWIS: Louis, I'm sorry.
>> GALPIN: ...he's the silent producer.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, Producer Louis named as Louis
but he spells it Louis which really bugs me
because my last name is Lewis and I spell
it Lewis.
He's not on camera today because he's phenomenal
handsomeness...
>> But he could be.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...would...
>> NO, no, no.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...would cause all of us to look
hideous in comparison.
>> Now, Lewis, the way you spell it...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> ...is the American fashion.
>> GALPIN: That's true.
>> The Louis I spell it is the French way
and the original.
>> GALPIN: I see.
That's true.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, like King Louis?
>> Yes.
All 15, 16 or 20 of them.
Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: That is [INDISTINCT] something
like that.
>> NI-LEWIS: And did they ask...
>> GALPIN: So are...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you to pronounce it Louis...
>> GALPIN: Are you saying...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...like some American dude?
>> GALPIN: ...you're French Loyalty then?
>> Not anymore than you are Scottish.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
I'm not Scottish.
>> NI-LEWIS: You're crap.
>> GALPIN: That's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Let's go.
>> GALPIN: All right.
This is--anyway, it's kind of cool.
It sort of combines falling tower action with
math.
You know, definitely in terms of tablet, there's
a little bit of work to be done, you know,
it's--and I was actually a little surprised
to see this game was a landscape game.
It actually starts off in portrait and it
goes to landscape.
In general, if you're going to lock to one
dimension, you should kind of lock to one
dimension, you know, whether--if you're going
to have a tile screen that's in landscape,
then your game should be in landscape [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
You never want to make the user actually...
>> GALPIN: You have to rotate the device.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...rotate the tablet.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Unless--well, unless you're just
trying to get obese children to exercise or
try to stand.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, I wish somebody had
done that for me when I was young.
>> GALPIN: So, maybe that's why they called
it Maths Twister and it occurred because you
have twist the tablet.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, that's a good point.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: I had just assumed that it was,
you know, what Mormons do for flirting.
>> GALPIN: You have to...
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, it's funny because...
>> GALPIN: ...explain that offline.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's funny because I actually--I
was visiting some friends, some, you know,
they went to school in Brigham Young University.
>> GALPIN: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, they brought out this video
and [INDISTINCT] wasn't the sexiest game of
twister you've ever seen with...
>> GALPIN: Oh, yeah, so that...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Well, that being twisters--I would
say it's beyond flirting there.
That's--twister is sort of in the heavy, heavy,
heavy, petting already when you get to like
that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly, right?
>> GALPIN: Yeah, totally.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, totally.
>> GALPIN: It's crazy.
Yes, drunken, not drunken.
Completely sober, party twister at BYU.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Let's do it.
>> GALPIN: You know, all these things I never
knew about.
All right.
So that's Maths Twister.
You would definitely--I think the biggest
issues that I have are tablet optimization
in terms of that.
I think, true, the game is fine on the phone.
We play it all on a tablet.
Why?
Because this has cool HDMI and it's running
Jelly Bean.
Thank you.
All right.
So, one more game which is also portrait.
It is Jungle Jumper and no, there's nothing
sexual about this game, just in case you're
curious.
There's no theme here.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: We weren't initially thinking
about that.
But now, I can't unhear it.
>> GALPIN: I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
To all our viewers out there, forget about...
>> NI-LEWIS: So, the thing I love about Jungle
Jumper is this like Stuart Little title screen
they've got.
It's like--it's seriously...
>> GALPIN: You're a rat.
>> NI-LEWIS: But you know what, it's not Stuart
Little.
I don't--it's just this--I don't know if you've
ever heard of this, but Abel's Island.
>> GALPIN: Oh, okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Do you know what I'm talking
about?
It was like a Newbery Award Winner.
>> GALPIN: You can actually jump off the side.
I've never done that before.
I didn't realize you could die jumping off--yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean, seriously, did you read
Abel's Island?
>> GALPIN: No, I didn't actually.
I didn't.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
All right.
Well, in that case, we can't share a moment.
>> GALPIN: I like the fact of the...
>> NI-LEWIS: Just believe me, the Abel's Island
guy looked exactly like the Jungle Jumper
guy.
>> GALPIN: Okay.
But I do like the fact that you actually get
nicely and soundly eaten by these guys when
you jump on them.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
They got some good animations.
I mean, obviously, it wasn't made for a tablet
in the sense that the background graphics
are a little fuzzy at this resolution.
That's always a little bit disappointing especially
when you can see that, you know, they're pretty
much Vector graphics, so they probably could
have been...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...rescaled and not too much
expense, but....
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I mean, this game is designed to be small.
>> NI_LEWIS: You can do this thing.
>> GALPIN: I would love to see it have a little
more animation than it does, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: It's like...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and to tell the truth,
I mean, this is sort of like [INDISTINCT]
where it's...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...actually not as fun on a tablet
because it's meant to have a smaller place.
>> GALPIN: I--honestly, I do love [INDISTINCT]
on a tablet though.
>> NI-LEWIS: I like--well, on a phone though,
it's so much easier.
>> GALPIN: It is easy.
I ran into his butt.
There we are.
>> NI-LEWIS: Really?
He ate you?
>> GALPIN: I was--I was--no, I didn't eat--he
didn't eat me.
I was just butt killed.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's disturbing.
>> GALPIN: I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
So, let's see.
What else coming up?
Well, next week, I think, either next week
or the week after you should see the ceremonial
unkegging of our Android fifth anniversary
ale.
>> GALPIN: Very exciting.
I was...
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> GALPIN: The whole team has been looking
forward to this.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a--what is it?
>> GALPIN: Yeah, he hasn't eaten you at all.
Yeah, sorry, go on.
>> NI-LEWIS: They've blended two malts and
three hops.
I can't remember off the top of my head, but
they are--but I hear it was the inaugural
outing of our new brewery and I understand
it ended up a little hoppier than we wanted
to.
Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Interesting.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Just a little accident with the
hops, but that's all right...
>> GALPIN: So, we made--we made more of an
IPA?
>> NI-LEWIS: ...because we like the hops.
>> That is the California thing guys.
That's very fitting.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, hops.
>> GALPIN: It is.
>> NI-LEWIS: Hops, yeah, pretty much.
It's because probably it make you fat.
>> You know, that wasn't an accident.
I actually did that by design behind the scenes.
>> GALPIN: I see.
Spiked it with extra hop.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, Daniel Feemster.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Ruined the fifth anniversary
ale.
>> In your words ruined.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> Not my words.
>> GALPIN: He made our fifth anniversary into
a bitter drink to swallow.
>> NI-LEWIS: Did you do that with our--with
our code too?
Just like sneak in at night and...
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...do some ninja chickens?
>> GALPIN: That's right.
>> I can't neither confirm nor deny that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Got you.
>> GALPIN: Here we have Daniel Fem ninja chicken
master.
>> NI-LEWIS: I totally believe that.
>> GALPIN: I do, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Every now and then you just find
a rogue feature and then...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
It's like how did that get that ninjas?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> GALPIN: That's what happens, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's totally ninjas.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Wi-fi direct, that was a total ninja feature.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It really was.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
Media code [INDISTINCT] code.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: The total ninja feature.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> GALPIN: So, yes, continue to get on the
moderator.
We actually do look at your suggestions and
the best of these games we do present over
to our buddies over at the Google Play team
and say, "Please, take a look at them."
They may or may not feature them.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: Like...
>> NI-LEWIS: And not only that, but we actually--we
are working on some collections of our very
own.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: We're...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, we're very excited about
that.
We've seen that collections actually are fun
people who like them.
I was really excited to see the retro gaming
collection which--you know, we talk a lot
about retro game tiles here and we--said,
"We really wanted to see some really cool..."
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, really want to do a collection
because we're like, "Well, you can't put a
retro game on the front page of Google Play."
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because a lot of people aren't
going to understand.
>> GALPIN: What the heck is this, man?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It's going to blow their mind, you know.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: We're not part of their system.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly, you know, like 8-bit
audio and low res graphic.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
But...
>> GALPIN: But for people who want it...
>> NI-LEWIS: Great.
>> GALPIN: ...it's awesome.
>> NI-LEWIS: I collect it up, yeah, absolutely.
>> GALPIN: I'm like, "Oh, yes, I'm saving
my childhood right here."
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm totally--yeah.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Back when I didn't read Abel's Odyssey.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's okay because you had a
childhood with 8-bit graphics.
I used to dream of 8-bit graphics.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
I remember when I was a child, I used live
in a shoebox.
>> NI-LEWIS: With a lid?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
You're inside a lid, lucky man.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
We're punchy.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, indeed.
>> NI-LEWIS: We talk about our games, talked
about some game development.
We are going to be shifting this.
The show, right, time wise?
>> GALPIN: Maybe.
I don't know.
We might be.
Watch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Big change is coming up.
>> GALPIN: Big chage.
>> NI-LEWIS: We will announce it on Google
Plus.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: But basically, we just have to
get through this month and then we have not--well,
you know.
>> GALPIN: Well, drink some more.
Drink some more.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
We get through this month and we are going
to change things up.
So, keep an eye on us and keep the comments
coming.
Now, let's see what people are saying on the
comment stream.
God, you guys suck so bad.
>> We actually--we actually had typical....
>> GALPIN: [INDISTINCT] that needs more specifics.
>> ...Youtube comments.
>> NI-LEWIS: Really?
Are there people being like...
>> Okay.
So, here is a question about the Transformer
Prime.
Is the Transformer the best Android tablet
or do you guys just use it because [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, the Transformer has some
advantages.
It is not--definitely not a bad Android tablet.
I don't know I'd go so far to say it's the
best.
For--as far as things that are shipping now
that we can get our hands on and reliably
get several backup units, it is the very best
at providing HDMI out.
It's got really good HDMI out options.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Asus added some things to the
base Android system that allow it to do things
like rotate in a portrait mode.
So, that makes our show a lot easier.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
That's--I mean, that's the primary reason
we're using it on the show.
We have them and they have this really cool
feature.
You know, we don't have HDMI on our tablet
sad to say, you know, on the Nexus 7.
So, if we had an Nexus 7.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: I mean, a Nexus tablet HDMI, we
might use it.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean, if you think about it,
the Nexus 7 in a lot of ways is a stripped
down Transformer Prime.
>> GALPIN: In a lot of ways.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's, you know, it's got the--essentially,
the same processing power, but a smaller screen,
no rear camera, you know...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...all the options are taken
off.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So fortunately we have a lot
of experience with that chipset and that piece
of hardware, so...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's a lot easier to show.
Now, there are some disadvantages to the Transformer
Prime.
It's--out of all of the--it's sort of the
odd man out on rendering.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Unlike almost all mobile chips,
it's not a tile renderer; it's forward renderer.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that means that it's very,
very sensitive to performance characteristics
that the tiler can handle very easily and
vice versa.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, so, like, you know, for example,
you know, there's just three different renderers
essentially on Android.
We have tile-based, deferred tile-based and
we have immediate mode or direct rendering
[INDISTINCT] on this.
And this tablet is--this chipset is really
cool if you need to do some really clever
effects that involve reading stuff back out
of the buffer, because the buffer is updated
in the, you know, in these thing.
The screen is updated in real time.
It was actually really fast to go and read
stuff out.
With the tile-based renderer or deferred renderer,
it means that it has to reconstruct that piece
of the buffer when you want in the middle
of rendering and that can slow you down in
immense amount.
So there are certain kinds of full screen
effects that this kind of chipset can do that
are very difficult to do on a tile-based renderer.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it's--you know, when you
think about the way the hardware is put together,
it's not so much as tile-based renderer is
bad at it...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's that--it's significantly
better at not doing that and it...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, that...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, so...
>> GALPIN: There we go.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...so in other words, you're
not--you're not actually doing something that...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS:...that the hardware is bad at,
it's just that it has to...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...forgo a whole set of optimizations
[INDISTINCT]
>> GALPIN: Right.
And it promise this, you know, this hardware
is designed to do work the other way and so,
what this--so the tile-based renderers tend
to actually have performance problems when
you start having to force them in the sort
of direct mode rendering because they just...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...weren't designed to work that
way.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
On the other hand, tile-based renderers excel
at some things, you know, for instance if
you're doing rebacks from a frame for blending,
they're--they can be very, very fast.
>>GALPIN: Absolutely, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Many tile-based renderers, especially
the ones that are fully deferred and have
geometry sorting, are incredible at dealing
with completely unsorted geometry...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...which is a real benefit because...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...sorting geometry is, A, not
actually a tractable problem.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You can--you can get close, but
it's sort of a traveling salesman thing and
so...
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But also, it takes up a lot of
CPU resources, so...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
Now, that being said, a lot of other drivers
for tile-based renderers also do some of that
sorting...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...inventing on the CPU drivers.
So there is--there is additional CPU load
already in a tile-based renderer just kind
of to begin with and it...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, I mean, it's always a...
>> GALPIN: And it...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...cooperation between the CPU
and the...
>> GALPIN: ...and then--yeah...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...GPU, yeah.
>> GALPIN: And then the magic sauce really
isn't, you know, the big the trace how much
is done where?
It's, you know, it's kind of...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...and exactly, you know, how...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's very true.
>> GALPIN: It's like that, you know, but basically--but,
yeah, so in theory also--in theory is that
and this isn't really proven, but that the
immediate mode guys would say when you get
into a really, really huge amount of geometry
when you start doing things like having procedural
geometry basically.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: That you start running into things
that immediate mode renderers do better than
tile-based renderers.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: And I think the jury is still out.
We'll have to wait to see what happens with
the--with...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, nobody's going to do that,
right?
Not more effective...
>> GALPIN: Well, okay, okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I'd be really surprised.
>> GALPIN: OpenGeo is starting to add this
kinds of features in, so I think--you know,
I think we'll have to look, you know, five
years down the line, we're going to definitely
have APIs and chips that'll support, you know,
doing that kind of geometry.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, but the thing is it's not--it's
not so much that...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...the sheer amount of geometry.
It's--the same reason that sorting is a different
problem.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, you know, you're right.
>> NI-LEWIS: But, you know, on a tiler, you're
really dealing with just a very large number
of frustra basically.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, you've already pre-clipped
a lot of your trial, so the chances of getting
interpenetration...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is very low.
Now, at the point where we are sitting...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...as application developers...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...when we say sort your geometry,
we're not actually thinking about sorting
your trials.
We're usually thinking about sorting it on
the object level, right?
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because we'll draw entire BBOs
at a time.
>> GALPIN: Exactly, and that's...
>> NI-LEWIS: So, that's actually...
>> GALPIN: ...and that's...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's a difficult problem because
you get these interpenetrating things.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
And that's actually a big challenge.
It's a challenge anyways, because you also
have certain geometry that is translucent.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: And so you actually have to maintain
that in proper, you know, front to back order...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...while you actually want to maintain
all of your geometry that isn't translucent
in back to front order and so...
>> NI-LEWIS: I...
>> GALPIN: ...you have to--you have to watch
out for all those interdependencies as well.
So this is...
>> NI-LEWIS: But it's not like it's, you know,
I mean, this isn't a secret to anybody because...
>> GALPIN: No.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...desktop cards have been doing
this for a long, long time.
It's really...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...only on the mobile space that
tilers are super popular.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But a lot of it is because--as
you're saying, you know, with deferred renderers--I'm
sorry, with medium renderers, you get more
predictable performance...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's easier to reason about
what the GPU is doing.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>>.NI-LEWIS: It's easier to do multi-pass
effect, but--and it's easier to take advantage
of these, you know, super long shaders that
you got too.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But it doesn't mean that when
you're in much more resource constrained environment...
>>GALPIN: Yeah, it's...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they don't shine.
>> GALPIN: They don't shine, exactly.
And so--and I think that--so it is interesting.
So one of the thing--one of the thing that's
nice about this is, one, you see that most
of the games are really well on it.
I mean, honestly...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...you know, the vast majority
of games on Android do great on the Transformer
Prime and it's really exciting also for us--the
other thing that's about Transformer Prime
is they did get Jelly Bean and it's really,
really nice.
Like the difference in smoothness when this
guy went into Jelly Bean was huge, because
it felt fast to begin with.
But as soon as we...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I never had a real problem
with it.
But--yeah, when...
>> GALPIN: But when you see Jelly Bean on
this...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's the same way...
>> GALPIN: ...it's like...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...like my Galaxy Nexus when
I upgraded it to Jelly Bean, I'm like, wow.
I feel like I just got a new phone.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And it's because the--you know,
we did a lot of work which we're actually
really hoping to bring to you...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...over the next few months.
It just talks about how you can dejunk your
applications the same way we dejunk the operating
system.
Mostly because all the guys did the dejunking...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...sit, like, two cubes away
from us and...
>> GALPIN: And then they're like, "When are
you going to do this online, dude?"
>> NI-LEWIS: They actually hate us and they
are like, "God, would you go away?"
But...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, we bugged them all the time.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...we have listening devices.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And when we say, bugged them...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...we mean actually microphones
in their office.
>> GALPIN: So, we...
>> NI-LEWIS: We get all their secrets...
>> GALPIN: The important thing is we added
this too...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...nothing is safe.
>> GALPIN: ...called Systrays.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> GALPIN: And Systrays is really, really
awesome.
So, I'll show an example.
So on one GPU, we could actually look at Systrays
since they are--the GPU is rendering here
and the thread went to sleep for this period
of time...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...and then the GPU was rendering
here.
Why did the thread go to sleep?
Well, the thread went to sleep because that
point we didn't read back from the GPU.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: And we could say--and that was
that the entire chunk of time which we could
actually measure and you can see that in Systrays.
It was actually...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm, exactly.
>> GALPIN: ...the GPU going, "Hey, well, I'm
going to do a bunch of calculation now.
This sucks."
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, now, remember of course
that there's two components to any read back,
right?
There is the--there is the fact that you're,
you know, you have to stall out the GPU writing
side.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But you also have to make sure
that the resource isn't in use on either side.
So it's...
>> GALPIN: Yes, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it's not just--sorry.
So, you need to collect the tiles...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and do all and, you know,
collapse your deferred renderer.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: And you also need to do a synchronization
between the CPU and GPU and that's what really
kills you.
And one thing that we've noticed with video
is that no matter how fast you are or how
good you...
>> GALPIN: That's why cache coherent CPUs
and GPUs are iconic kickass...
>> NI-LEWIS: No, no...
>> GALPIN: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...because here's the problem...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...it's not actually--it's not
actually a synchronization problem, it's more
a sequencing problem...
>> GALPIN: I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: I was just kidding.
>> NI-LEWIS: That is--yeah, your point.
But anyway, the problem is--or the solution
I should say...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is that you just never want
to have the GPU and CPU holding on to the
same resource at once.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And so--and, you know, if you're
working on a desktop part, you already know
how this works because you have to deal with
PCI Synchronization...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...and the solution is staging
buffers.
So, you don't do a read back into a texture
and then immediately use it.
You do a read back...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...this frame while you're reading
the read back that you did three frames ago.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, it's actually point--one
of the things people do actually for reflection...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...is that you actually don't calculate
a reflection every frame...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> GALPIN: ...but you use, you know, every
other frame, you know, maybe every two frames,
you know, depending on how much you're allowed.
All right, well, now let's calculate reflection
and we'll apply that and that's from two frames
ago, but that's okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: Because actually the user can't
really tell because on top of some other wavy
meshy thing and...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right, right.
>> GALPIN: And...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, and a lot of it depends
of course on who is doing the read back.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean, because the problem is
that the GPU is considered to be a user of
that texture from the point that a draw call
involving it had submitted to the...
>> GALPIN: uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...point where it retires.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, that's actually a huge length
of time that the GPU is not in fact using
the texture.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And in fact most of these GPUs
are executing completely serially.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, for instance it's no problem
for the GPU to read back a texture as long
as it's not actually writing to it right now.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But having the CPU read it back
or if you need to do any kind of processing
that involves the CPU which as you noted before...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you don't really know because
a lot of this--the magic happens in the driver.
>> GALPIN: Inside the driver.
>> NI-LEWIS: And each one of these...
>> GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...chips is not just a self contained
magical graphics...
>> GALPIN: Not at all, no.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...producing unit.
It's part of an ecosystem of software that
lives in multiple places.
>> GALPIN: And--yeah.
So, it's interesting.
And then sometimes you actually--for some
of these effects, you actually can do them
entirely on the CPU, you know, like some of
the guys...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...some of the guys, you just fake
it out.
You're like, "All right, I know I've got a
problem with this geometry.
Let's calculate it on the CPU.
Let's not even get the GPU involved and we'll..."
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, sometimes that's your best
choice, right?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because--especially if you've
got things where you got a lot of recursion
and you...
>> GALPIN: [INDISTINCT] Oh, yeah, recursion,
yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Or...
>> GALPIN: What was that?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah, yeah, feedback, right?
>> GALPIN: So, feedback.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, so let's say you're doing
an IRR filter...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...which depends on feeding back
the results of previous calculations.
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, that's incredibly difficult
for a GPU to do well because...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...unless you're doing entire
frame...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...buffers at a time, right?
So, but the GPU is for like...
>> GALPIN: Well, you know and that's why they
go great on these--on these newer devices.
We have some very, very powerful CPUs with,
you know, Vector processing...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...built in to them, you know.
Neons can do a lot of really cool stuff.
So, it's--it definitely is an opportunity
to actually go and balance some of the load
between the CPU or GPU and especially when
you get into this tilers, you can really--you
can start to guess at what they're going to
do badly and you'll usually be right.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
I think...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And then that's it, the world's...
>> GALPIN: Are there...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...world record for the longest
answer to complete a long the question.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Next question.
>> GALPIN: Yes.
Is there anything else in the screen that's
interesting at all?
>> Yes, so a question from Bugsize.
He's asking [INDISTINCT] keep pushing hardware
speed, won't programming become really easy?
No more optimizations needed?
>> GALPIN: Well, it--I guess at some point,
way in the distant future.
The thing is we keep pushing kind of two things.
One is the expectation for quality.
So, you know, while, you know, while we're
pushing more Geometer, we're pushing more
textures, we're pushing more layering.
And so we're keeping up the hardware.
The second thing is we're going high resolution,
you know.
I mean and as--and every time we go a higher
resolution, it's kind of funny we sort of
take a step forward and a step back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> GALPIN: A step forward and a step back.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
Well, and so I have my own personal answer
for you.
And of course the answer is yes, see JavaScript,
right?
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because--I mean, that's why we
have the web is because this incredibly inefficient
mode of programming that grew out of the mark
up language and an experiment in Computer
Science...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...has now become capable of
running almost anything as long as you're
on a massively multi-core of computer with
gigabytes of RAM.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: But on--and so I think that that
trend will probably continue...
>> GALPIN:: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...especially now that we've
really gotten for multi-core into the desktop.
But here's the problem...
>> GALPIN: For certain class of games, I think--I
think we won't have to optimize.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, here's the problem for
mobile though, a little thing I like to call
the Laws of Physics.
There is certain amount of weight you're willing
to carry in your pocket.
>> GALPIN: You cannot change the Laws of Physics.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Thank you.
I was waiting for that.
>> GALPIN: I know you were.
>> NI-LEWIS: The--wait.
That does make you evil, Scotty?
>> GALPIN: Does, it does?
You're right.
All right.
Never mind.
I don't know what I...
>> NI-LEWIS: Nice.
>> GALPIN: ...thought I was doing there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Anyway, the point is, so you
have a specific amount of battery.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: You have a specific size and
specific tolerant for heat.
Now, if you've ever felt the back of let's
say a giant, you know, Mac Pro or a--one of
these big Windows workstations or anything
like that.
You know that the type of computational power
that it takes to run let's say...
>> GALPIN: It totally beats my house.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...[INDISTINCT] yeah.
>> GALPIN: It's awesome like I don't even
need to turn on the heater at certain times.
I just turn up that [MAKES NOISE]
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, all I do is check my Gmail.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Boom.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
That's why I called it VA, right?
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
So, you know, none of that is going to take
away from the miracle that is modern computing.
But to get that into the size--I mean it is
somewhat that you could...
>> GALPIN: It somewhat less than [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Well--right.
And it's the same way that you can be like--well,
gee, you know, Transatlantic Ocean Liners
can produce huge amounts of horse powers.
So, I guess we don't have to worry about designing
cars to be aerodynamic.
Well, no, because you're never going to get
that, you know, that engine...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...into that size and make it
work efficiently, right?
>> GALPIN: I think on mobile it's always good
to--it's always good when you can design something
efficiently.
You can always help the user's battery life.
You know, we--you know, sometimes the reason
why people stop playing mobile games is like,
"This game is sucking away all of my battery."
And, you know, so being more efficient is
always better.
Now, that being said, you know, we are getting
to a point in which certain kinds of optimizations
aren't as important.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> GALPIN: And for a lot of games.
I mean there's...
>> NI-LEWIS: Very sure.
>> GALPIN: There's a lot--there's a whole
series of games that just doesn't have to
care about certain things.
But memory is always an important resource.
We have a lot of devices that have, you know,
different sizes of VMs, different sizes of
actual physical memory in different amount
of stuff that's running on top of them.
So it's always good to be resource sensitive...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: ...on this resource constraints...
>> NI-LEWIS: But there are tradeoffs, you
know.
I mean...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...sometimes you can--you can
trade memory for greater CPU.
>> GALPIN: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's less the case than it--than
it used to be.
CPUs have really gotten faster, memory buses
have quite kept up...
>> GALPIN: Well, I mean we can--we can--we
could make cars more sufficient today.
We could build them out of titanium.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: But the problem is it would be
really, really, really, expensive and no one
would but them.
So, you know, you...
>> NI-LEWIS: Except for you.
I think--don't you have titanium car now?
>> GALPIN: No, I don't.
But that sounds like a brilliant idea.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
I'm mixing you up with Sergey.
>> GALPIN: Exactly.
Yeah, I know.
People do that.
It's the beard.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, that same thing, yeah.
He owns a titanium car.
>> GALPIN: So, in any case, you know, so I
mean there's a point in which obviously you're--what
I'm saying is that in terms of efficiency,
there is a point in which you want to--you
have to stop and say, "Look, it's just not
worth it."
We've hit the 95 percentile of what, you know,
what we're going to get.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> GALPIN: But I think that, you know, especially
in mobile it's a--forced us to relook at efficiency
and say, "You know, this is really important
stuff," which is fun because we love it to
work Computer Scientists.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
>> GALPIN: And we love actually looking at
those kinds of problems.
>> NI-LEWIS: Remember though that actually
speed is not as important as it once was.
But smoothness is.
So a lot of times, we're doing things that
don't actually increase the speed of the application.
What they do is they increase the responsiveness
and make certain that the animations can play
at 60 frames per second.
So making something twice as fast isn't hard.
Making it consistently 60 FPS when you started
out at 15 FPS or 30 FPS is often extremely
difficult because...
>> GALPIN: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...especially if you're trying
to make it consistent, consistent.
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
And again, if you're trying to, you know,
one of the real challenges on Android is you're
trying to use a very small amount of memory
targeting a very high resolution screen and
you are fighting the fact that you've also
have garbage collection going, that every
once in a while that's going to take 20-30
milliseconds.
>> NI-LEWIS: I love how a very small amount
of memory.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, I know.
>> NI-LEWIS: And is--yeah.
>> GALPIN: Yeah, like 64 megabytes of memory,
you know, is--which is...
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, right--or, you know, I
mean if we have a gig or two gigs in a device,
I mean that's like...
>> GALPIN: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I'd use to dream of that.
>> GALPIN: Well, exactly.
I mean I actually--I actually remember that
16 megabytes memory for a [INDISTINCT] or
for a computer was just something beyond like
that was what professional photo workstations
had and that was like $5,000...
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah, exactly.
>> GALPIN: ...worth of memory.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> GALPIN: The fact that we have that for
a process--so, you know, it's always going
to take things into consideration.
That's what I mean when I talk about quality,
you know, the quality keeps going up.
We keep finding ways of using those computing
resource.
So I think that we're not going to be at a
time anytime soon.
Maybe 20-30 years out, we're going to be able
to say, "Yeah, you know, we don't need to
worry about this."
But I think that for--we still have a pretty
long cycle before that stuff becomes unimportant.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
>> GALPIN: All right.
I think--I think--is there anything else exciting?
>> NI-LEWIS: Anything else on the screen that's
just really knocking you out?
No?
>> GALPIN: No.
All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> GALPIN: Well, thank you for joining us.
As always, vote stuff up in the moderator
page.
Let us know what you're playing.
Let us know what you want us to talk about.
We're going to try mix up the format of the
show a little.
We've got some exciting stuff coming on as
soon as we get some sleep.
So, thank you once again for joining us and
our friends over at [INDISTINCT].
It was actually getting a fan for providing
this delicious IPA that we're drinking now.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
God bless us everyone.
Little Android play us up.
>> GALPIN: God Bless us everyone.
Here we are.